[Música]
porque nos da tanto miedo hablar del
machismo a los hombres porque nos
obtendremos tanto como hombres cuando se
habla de machismo y dado que es un foro
con un concepto como fieles como sin
miedo me parece muy interesante exponer
o compartirles 13 reflexiones
la primera reflexión tiene que ver con
terrenos donde está tanto alarde
machismo porque definitivamente pensamos
que se están teniendo con nosotros con
los hombres tenemos que empezar a
entender que el machismo lejos de
criticar al hombre por el simple hecho
de ser hombre está criticando está
cuestionando nuestras conductas en este
caso nuestras conductas comportamientos
códigos interacciones palabras lógicas
de lo que se supone que es en un hombre
y lo que se supone que es ser un hombre
desafortunadamente tiene que ver todavía
hoy mucho con hacer menor menospreciar
de se empoderan a todo aquello que se
considera femenino a todo aquello que
consideramos más débil todo aquello que
no consideramos masculino como lo
masculino se construye todavía o viene
oposición a lo femenino todo eso que no
es que es considerado asociado a lo
femenino es más débil consideramos desde
esta lógica machista que las mujeres son
más débiles y que todo lo que sea social
o feminismo es más débil por lo tanto
cuando se critica el machismo
generalizamos nosotros en primer lugar y
pensamos que se están metiendo con
nosotros tenemos que empezar a romper
esa asociación porque al final del día
ese hombre es una condición a ganar ese
congreso la condición a ganar en el
sentido en el que tenemos que ir
descubriendo aprendiendo desaprendiendo
cuestionándonos cómo salir de esta
ideología machista en la que estamos
metidos como hombres al pensar que sólo
hay una única forma es en hombres y
lejos de ser así tienen y hay tantas
formas de expresarnos como hombres
nuestra identidad masculina como hombres
hay en este planeta entonces si somos
cuatro mil millones de hombres o la
mitad de la población como mínimo
debería haber tantas miles de formas
millones de formas de expresarnos como
versiones del planeta a partir de ahí
este machismo o esta mala decodificación
esta mala interpretación de lo que se
supone que significa ser un hombre que
está asociado a una única manera y como
decimos hay tantas como hombres sabemos
también está mala interpretación no
entiende de orientación sexual
compañeros
nuestra habitación sexual no nos quita
lo machista e insisto dejemos de
entender lo que se habla de machismo se
están metiendo con nosotros porque al
ser conductas que menospreciaron
femenino ese tipo de conductas las puede
tener cualquier persona en la población
hay mujeres machistas como yo más
machistas pero desafortunadamente en
número está en porcentaje estadístico
somos nosotros los protagonistas de
estas agresiones esos controles están
mal la forma de entender en la autoridad
del poder la fuerza la habilidad la
valentía y todas estas cualidades
asociadas al lo masculino como si fuese
una única forma de entender las todas
ellas por lo tanto en da igual si bien
son orante de sexual distinta a la
heterosexual da igual si eres gay te da
igual si eres lesbiana como he dicho tu
orientación sexual no te quita lo
machista todas las personas pueden ser
machistas sí pero por en un porcentaje
altísimo de la población por ejemplo si
vamos a ver las estadísticas 95%
nosotros también mundial cometemos
homicidios del mundo pero también
tres veces más por ejemplo en méxico
hombres que mujeres y los hombres que
mueren en méxico mueren a manos de otros
hombres como los hombres que ponen el
mundo en porcentaje estadístico mueren a
manos de otros hombres es decir las
violencias en los homicidios las
agresiones y todo lo que tiene que ver
con este mal entendimiento de esa fuerza
y esa valentía la estamos protagonizando
estadísticamente los varones y eso está
muy ligado a la tercera reflexión que
les quiero compartir también tenemos que
entender los límites del respeto con las
personas que nos rodean porque desde
esta visión a los centristas del mundo
hemos entendido que los límites del
mundo los ponemos nosotros como ejemplo
los límites del mundo los ponemos los
hemos puesto los hombres fíjense en la
ciencia la política la economía la
religión los límites de lo posible o lo
imposible en esos paradigmas son los que
se construyen en nuestras sociedades son
límites son visiones que son
eminentemente masculinas la historia no
la cuentan los vencedores de historia
hemos contado los hombres en una visión
sumamente antelo centrista del mundo
donde la política la religión la ciencia
la economía
han contado se han construido como
nosotros como protagonistas no con la
misión de los centristas de esos
paradigmas de esas disciplinas y es
necesario empezar a entender que esos
límites lo que es posible en esos
conocimientos en nuestros saberes nos
hemos puesto a nosotros por lo tanto
tenemos que entender el límite también
cuando viene del otro lado tenemos que
entender empezar a incorporar esas
cosmovisión esos puntos de vistas de las
mujeres y de otras identidades porque es
obvio y lógico que así es la única forma
en la que vamos a evolucionar más rápido
otro punto muy importante que quiero
compartirles este proceso de aprendizaje
de esta mala interpretación de lo que se
supone que es ser un hombre si hablamos
de la masculinidad y como hemos
interpretado en una ideología machista
en una cultura machista que en primer
lugar nos afecta nos afecta como varones
en primer lugar a nosotros todo este
sometimiento todo este control todo es
atentar e intentar dominar intentar este
usar la fuerza de manera excesiva para
probar nuestro punto nos ha llevado a
una muy mala gestión es una muy mala
gestión de nuestras emociones donde a
nivel mundial el 81 por ciento de los
hombres protagonizamos los suicidios
donde en méxico por ejemplo hay 15
millones de hombres con depresión donde
estamos compitiendo por cosas tan
absurdas como pasar un semáforo en rojo
y el 80% de los accidentes
automovilísticos por esta competencia
estúpida está en un semáforo también
somos protagonistas nosotros en
definitiva todas estas cualidades
arquetípicas van enfocadas en esta
aparente y única forma válida de ser
hombres es lo que ha construido esta
cultura machista que tenemos que
construir y como punto número 4 esta
deconstrucción es infinita compañeros es
infinita empezamos a observar nuestros
prejuicios como empezamos a
cuestionarnos a que nos preguntas
incómodas pero esto no acaba nunca
probablemente vamos a morirnos con
prejuicios vamos a morirnos con sesgos
por eso de construcción que es infinita
lo que es interesante es empezar a ser
conscientes de eso después de esas
cuestionamientos y auto cuestionamientos
en lugar de seguir cuestionando a otros
géneros a otras mujeres otras personas
por lo que hacen empezar a preguntarnos
qué tanta responsabilidad tenemos allí y
cómo nos he dicho a nivel estadístico
tenemos mucha para que ellas estén
reivindicando en este caso por ejemplo
todas las desigualdades o toda la falta
de derechos fundamentales que nosotros
no hemos tenido que reivindicar entonces
preguntémonos eso ya mantener y entender
que efectivamente la igualdad debería
empezar en casa
pero estamos lejos de verlo así muchas
veces si entendemos que la casa es la
unidad mínima indivisible de eso que
llamamos país en el hogar cada hogar
sería esa unidad indivisible no quieren
finalmente es un edificio calle una
delegación cantón una colonia una ciudad
hemos estado es un país pues si todas
las casas realmente fuesen igualitarias
si se tratase de manera respetuosa así
hubiese diversidad e inclusión pues
probablemente no tendríamos muchas de
estas desavenencias e injusticias
sociales las tenemos porque el reflejo a
muchas veces de eso que es la casa
lejos de esa sociedad que son los
hogares son lugares donde no se practica
esta igualdad donde son lejos de ser
diversos e inclusivos donde la figura
paterna en muchos casos por ejemplo en
méxico ésta está ausente física y
emocionalmente de los hogares en un 40%
donde se confunde la autoridad con la
imposición con esto lo hace se hace así
porque lo digo yo y punto no importante
cuando empezamos a entender esa
presencia masculina muy mal enfocada
cuando está pero en un porcentaje muy
alto esa ausencia de roles de paternidad
de esa ausencia la implicación emocional
que finalmente hace también que muchos
hogares sean lugares muy poco inclusivos
muy poco igualitarios que muchas mujeres
generan dobles triples jornadas de
labores domésticas de responsabilidad
porque no hay una correspondencia a una
repartición de los errores porque esto
es de hombres y esto está mujeres y por
tanto es necesario entender que si
queremos que la limpieza en casa
realmente tenemos que generar una
repartición en diálogo de errores donde
como verde pensamos que no pensemos que
ayudemos en la casa estoy ayudando
porque cuando presiones que ayudas
presupones de que eso no te toca a ti se
trata de asumir que nos toca a todos y
todas las componentes de la casa
corresponder de manera corresponsable en
eso que se tiene que hacer no agravado
que no importa el género y en los
pañales tampoco por lo mismo está la
escoba y no el balón lo que nos va a
hacer probablemente mejores hombres no
en el sentido de que será conectarnos a
los cuidados al cuidado del hogar al
cuidado de nuestros hijos al cuidado de
nuestras relaciones al cuidado de
nuestros adultos mayores a nuestro
propio cuidado en primer lugar lo que
probablemente nos acercará a esa
igualdad de los hogar porque como
hombres
hemos estado totalmente desconectados de
las esferas de los cuidados del cuidado
propio el autocuidado del cuidado social
y de relaciones el cuidado de mi hogar
del cuidado del planeta por entender que
cuidar
supuestamente es una cualidad asociado a
lo femenino cuidar es de mujeres no hoy
las mujeres son las que cuidan las
cuidadoras y por nosotros somos los que
proveemos y es de mal entendimiento de
nuevo de estas cualidades y de estos
roles que estamos encarnando nos traen
muchos problemas porque luego cuidar es
una cualidad universal y humana y
podemos aprenderla como lo es el amor la
el prestar atención a los detalles el
amor es una cualidad que no entiende de
género cuidar también tenemos que
empezar a ponerla en práctica porque eso
nos va a llevar esta repartición de
roles esto y este involucramiento en las
esferas del cuidado nos va a llevar a
tener una agenda de conversaciones muy
incómoda que nos saque de estos robles
arquetípicos que hemos malinterpretado
en esta cultura machista de la cuales
como les digo somos copartícipes
protagonistas en un alto número
estadístico y al mismo tiempo también
este víctimas de nuestro propio machismo
y es importante empezar a cambiar esta
cultura de la cual formamos parte a
través de una agenda temática de temas
que nos incomoden y este es el siguiente
punto que les quiero tratar no a esta
cultura que hemos creado ayer
transformar esta cultura no sólo pasa
por establecer nuevos temas de
conversación entre nosotros por generar
nuevos tipos de relaciones y conexiones
con otros hombres por ver el silencio
cómplice sino también por entender que
así como nos corresponde a cada uno de
nosotros formar parte de ella también
les corresponde a las empresas cultura
privada en este caso ya los gobiernos
generar
espacios seguros en el ámbito y no
espera pública y por lo tanto es
necesario exigirles también que los
gobiernos inviertan en involucrar nos a
los hombres en esta creación de espacios
seguros en la esfera pública así como
las compañías en las culturas privadas
inviertan también en involucrarnos como
varones en involucrar los empleados a
sus líderes varones en este caso que
representamos el 80 por ciento del
liderazgo latinoamericano en
involucrarnos en esta transformación
cultural para que efectivamente dejemos
de sentirnos ofendidos conocerán de
estos temas y empecemos a entender que
somos parte fundamental de este cambio
de conseguir esta igualdad esta
diversidad y esta inclusión de todos
todas y todos por lo mismo tenemos que
empezar
hacernos cargo responsables de nuestra
propia gestión personal ya he dicho que
se empieza efectivamente teniendo en
cuenta que en la esfera que llamamos
como sociedad
tienen múltiples actores el gobierno
está individual empresas pero
necesitamos efectivamente
responsabilizarnos también desde cada
uno de nosotros y entender como les
decía antes que esto nos afecta el no
hacerlo nos afecta y tiene consecuencias
lo miremos por donde lo miremos para
nosotros en primer lugar y cuando
empezamos a entender que esto nos afecta
empezamos a
cuestionarnos a preguntarnos qué podemos
hacer al respecto y lo primero que
podemos hacer al respecto es algo muy
básico por ejemplo dejar de hablar de la
masculinidad dejar de perder la
masculinidad en singular porque eso
sigue sosteniendo una forma
aparentemente única aparentemente la
manera correcta o válida de expresarnos
o este identificarnos como hombres y
lejos de eso tenemos que empezar a
hablar de más cooley nidades porque solo
el hecho de cambiar al plural el
concepto y empezar a nombrarlo el plural
nos abre la pluralidad sobre la
posibilidad de incorporar otras muchas
formas de expresarnos como mujeres y la
pluralidad es diversidad tanto es desde
ahí empezamos hablar de masculinidad es
pero no de cualquier tipo de
masculinidad es sino de masculinidad es
positivas sí que significa positivas
masculinidad es que se dejen de
conductas sexistas por tanto anti
sexistas que se alejan de conductas
homofóbicas por tanto antiguo fóbicas
anti racistas anti hegemónicas en
definitiva masculinidad es que sea el
eje de la violencia y es cuando hablamos
de masculinidad es positivas anti
sexistas antimonopólicas anti racistas
antifascistas y las normas positivas
sino nuevas porque nuevo simplemente
escribe algo que es nuevo pero no
necesariamente mejor y por eso lo vemos
nuevo no y lo mejor lo positivo es mejor
y es positivo y más aún cuando estamos
definiendo que es positivo de esas
conductas violentas
finalmente para ir cerrando esta
conversación entender que todo esto que
les estoy diciendo y que englobamos en
este concepto que solemos llamar
igualdad en lejos de ser un discurso en
una charla texto en un discurso que
podemos tener una conversación que
podemos tener con nuestros amigos amigas
es un verbo porque es una práctica y
ahora cada día
este proceso de lograr igualdad de
derechos oportunidades este proceso de
cambiar patrones y conductas machistas
que nos afectan en primera lugar a
nosotros como les decía antes es un
proceso infinito es una práctica diaria
que probablemente no acabe nunca pero
que en algún punto tenemos que empezar
en esto implica pasar de una visión
androcéntrica del mundo donde pensamos
todavía seguimos inconscientemente mal
interpretando el concepto de jerarquía y
la jerarquía todos los sistemas vivos
del planeta tienen organizaciones
jerárquicas la jerarquía es algo
biológico que tiene millones de años de
antigüedad pero nuestra manera hoy como
animales consciente especie consciente y
dominante de este planeta es poder poner
justamente una conciencia de esa forma
de organización jerárquica y empezar
también a replantear la para que con una
sobrepoblación mundial empiece también a
ayudarnos a encontrarnos y conectarnos
en mayor igualdad de oportunidades y en
un contexto de mayor justicia social por
lo tanto eso pasa necesariamente por
cambiar esta visión androcentrista del
mundo y empezar a quitarnos del medio
dejar de pensar nos en ser el centro del
mundo y empezar a darnos cuenta de que
formamos parte de él
finalmente es solo decirles que nos
guste más o nos guste menos no formamos
parte de un patrón que tiende
estadísticamente a esto pérez díaz a
este mal entendimiento de las cualidades
arquetípicas masculinas se trata de ser
conscientes y salirnos de ese patrón
porque el problema no somos los hombres
y esto es bien importante que quiero
hacer dar con este problema no somos los
hombres pero si tenemos un problema en
cómo estamos interpretando y cómo
estamos entendiendo la masculinidad
entonces
quitémonos el miedo de apelar de esto de
estos temas quitémonos el miedo de
apelar del machismo y esta es una
invitación para hacerlo desde aquí desde
hoy y abrir la conversación para que
juntos desafiamos a machismo gracias
[Música]